so many John Dean it is not a fact
witness he's never talked to Dom McGann
he's never talked to president at Trump
he's never talked to Christopher Steele
so you can rule out him having any any
facts that might benefit the American
public he's not a legal expert on
obstruction he did pay his debt to
society
so I wouldn't have spent my five minutes
really litigating his criminal history
but he's not a fact witness so it begs
the question is Jerry Nadler why would
you call someone who can't help the
American people on the facts or the law
and the reality is Jason and you were
there almost as long as I was this story
they want they wanted to get it started
right after the inauguration and they
want to keep it going until November of
2020 and even having pathetic sad
hearings that don't benefit anyone other
than the folks who buy advertising on
television that's part of this effort to
keep it alive
well they don't even sell advertising on
c-span and I can't imagine people or
even wasting their time trying to watch
that clown show when you bring up two
convicted felons Michael Cohen and and
John Dean as the way you're gonna propel
this I don't know how ATS with a
straight face look in the camera and say
oh yeah we're trying to get to the
bottom and do the work of the American
people now part of what also happened is
on the case I'll tell you how they do
I'll tell you how they do yeah cuz
they're never there never ask about it
Jason okay that's how many times you've
you and I discussed and look you were
really really good with the media when
you were there I I constantly watched
you stop and talk to print reporters and
most of the rest of us wouldn't do it I
hope even you have realized now the
duplicity and the relativism with which
Republicans are covered versus Democrats
if you as the chairman of oversight had
called someone like John Dean who's not
a fact witness he's not a legal expert
about the best he can give you as a
day-in-the-life in federal prison that's
the best he's gonna be able to give you
you would have been excoriated you don't
hear anything about Nadler no no he read
about I mean II would even ask us those
questions is you'd a subpoena for Bryan
Pagliano the IT specialist for Hillary
Clinton who said he served four years in
the US with Hillary Clinton and had
never sent or received an email and we
he had an immunity agreement we asked
him to come before the committee and
almost nobody even covered the hearing
because he didn't show up I was there in
case you forgot I was there hey how
about how about six years worth of not
being able to get information from
President Obama's administration I mean
where was the outrage where the politico
Hill Washington Post articles about how
outrageous it is the executive branch is
not cooperating with legitimate
oversight you don't see any of it so
look I get that our former line of work
ain't that popular but folks in the
media are not trusted as much as we need
them to be in a robust thriving
democracy and at some point they're
gonna need they need to ask themselves
what I wonder why we're not trusted I
wonder why people think that we're in
the tank for the Democrats and I think
you see a little bit of that this week
no you see it every week along the way
now one of the day more than a little
yeah one of the things that also
happened this week is they wanted to
hold and they did vote in the Oversight
Committee committee you and I were both
on and both chaired to hold attorney
general bar and the Secretary of
Commerce Wilbur Ross in contempt I mean
I can't believe they did this but what
was your take on it you know Jason we
held Eric Holder in contempt for the
failure to produce documents you and I
were not the chairman at the time but
there is tension between the branches
over whether or not to produce documents
and whether or not there's been an
accommodation there's actually
litigation still ongoing on with this so
it's kind of like holding bar in
contempt for not turning over the Moller
report by law he cannot turn over
certain parts of it so you're gonna hold
him in contempt for following the law
and this instance they're holding Wilbur
and the Attorney General in contempt for
not turning over documents related to
something that's currently part of
litigation but if you can do it and get
away with it and never be questioned and
never
be challenged by your base or the media
why not
no I in the case of Wilbur Ross there's
a pending Supreme Court decision that's
going to happen at the end of the month
they have three scheduled witnesses from
the Department of Commerce Wilbur Ross
testified four hours before the
committee they have turned over 14
thousand documents and this rush to try
to hold them in contempt before the
Supreme Court comes about and there's
decision and yet nobody but nobody is
writing these stories because they don't
ask the court questions I've got just a
moment left but I want to get your take
on Andrew McCabe calling for the
impeachment of Donald J Trump what's
your take Oh JC I go back to the
criticism of Trump this week because he
it wasn't sure whether they'd call the
FBI I hope he does I would encourage him
to call the FBI but let's think about
who we would have gotten on the phone if
he had called in the summer of 2016
call me who thinks impeachments too good
for you
McCabe who despite his own legal
distractions wants to weigh in and say
Trump all to be impeached or Brennan who
wants to do one more than that and
actually put you on trial for treason a
crime for which you can be put to death
so that's who he's supposed to call in
the summer of 2016
I wish mccabe would just go on to deal
with his own legal issues I really don't
know anyone who gives a damn what Andy
McCabe thinks about impeachment and
don't roll I really don't other than the
reporter that asked him well I think you
soul he's in big huge legal trouble and
he better start lawyering up and I think
he's out there trying to spin his own
thing because that's where I'd put my
time I would devote my time on my own
legal issues are not weigh in on other
people's yeah well he's gonna be in a
world of hurt soon I can't wait for the
Inspector General's report I know you
and I think a lot of Michael Horowitz
and I'm sure he did a thorough job and
when he comes out and says I think is
probably gonna be as close to the fact
that you can probably get your right